I left this city unprotected by giving
up my power system i enabled him to
leave this earth last thing you need is
more medicalization I need my powers
back
what would you do that and recreating
particle accelerator explosion the last
time he was in a coma for nine months
know what I'm doing this could kill
myself I have to do
hey youtubers it's Charlie so new flash
trailer just teasing a little bit of
Flashpoint going on so I'll totally
explain what's going on what they're
doing from the comics who this new
character is that we see in the trailer
all kinds of awesome stuff happening so
the first big thing you probably
recognize the flashpoint stuff even if
you haven't seen my flash videos from
last week I talked a little bit about
how they're doing some flashpoint things
in that they're trying to recreate the
accident that gave Barry powers like
they do during the flashpoint storyline
the really fun thing about that too is
that they basically they have to strike
Barry with lightning so it really hurts
and it doesn't work the first time so
they have to do it twice so he gets
struck by lightning twice in rapid
succession if you don't have access to
the comic book I think the animated
movie Justice League flashpoint paradox
was on Netflix for a little while I'm
not exactly sure where that movie is
available for streaming but they do a
pretty good job of it in that too it's
just the part of Thomas Wayne in that
storyline is being played by Cisco and
Harrison wells
during the flashpoint storyline the
Justice League is already a pretty big
deal
so he tries to track down Bruce Wayne to
get help but he finds out that because
the timeline has changed that Thomas
Wayne is the person that became Batman
and bruises the one that died in the
alleyway so Thomas Wayne is like the
super dark version of Batman you can
kind of see how they're doing that with
earth - it's like crime syndicate earth
everybody is a really dark version of
themselves
but I will say Metallica Cisco riding
the lightning my favorite version of
Cisco so far I'm just gonna pretend like
he has a Metallica t-shirt on underneath
this jacket but the other big thing in
this trailer is this character right
here this is rupture Cisco's brother
from earth to in like the flash TV shows
doing this here we've met Cisco's
brother on earth one he's not a
metahuman on earth - he is a metahuman
and his powers are a little bit like
Cisco's in the comics it's a little bit
different because in the comics he has
two brothers Dante in Armando Armando is
the one that becomes rupture but on the
TV show I think they're just simplifying
it and it's going to be Dante because
it'll be someone that you recognize so
on the TV show
Cisco only has one brother on earth one
on earth two on earth - he's a metahuman
just like his brother in the comics
Cisco's name is always vibe but remember
the way they're playing with earth one
and earth two on the TV show evil earth
- Cisco's name was reverb in the comics
this rupture character also has a couple
different
he's called hard-lined he's called
rupture he's called reverb so just a
couple minor changes from the comics
they're just simplifying things a little
bit but the fun of this is just like
when Barry had the double take when he
saw dr. light Linda Park for the first
time he was like oh my god it's my old
girlfriend and she's evil with super
powers trying to kill me now it's gonna
be an even bigger version of that for
Cisco when the helmet comes off and he's
like oh my god it's Dante it's my
brother but you're evil and you're
trying to kill me one of the really cool
things I think they've done with the
evil earth - metahumans this year is
they've said that even though they're
evil they still have their own
relationships like killer frost just
tried to kill Caitlin so you know really
hardcore she's definitely evil but she
also loved her version of Ronnie Raymond
the same way earth one Caitlin loved her
Ronnie Raymond so at their core they
share a lot of the human emotions of
their earth-1 counterparts it just does
a really good job of making the
characters that much more real like
they're not just really simple mustache
twirling villains like rupture here
wants to kill team flash because they
killed his brother even though his
brother was a guyliner ponytail
douchebag but in related news they also
just released some information about
episode 22 that's the episode that katie
cassidy is guest starring in as like her
evil metahuman version from earth - her
name's gonna be black siren there's
gonna be a giant metahuman army it's
gonna be awesome that's all I'll say
about it now we can talk more about it
when we get closer but just think of it
is the giant team-up episode going into
the finale now remember there's still
the finale we don't know anything about
that yet but because there's been so
much flashpoint stuff going on this
season I'm expecting a version of
something from the flashpoint storyline
like somehow berry will fix a mistake
that has been made but the other really
crazy news you guys may have heard about
is that Marvel and Netflix just
confirmed a Punisher TV series for
Netflix that is it's a Netflix Punisher
series with Jon Bernthal of course I'll
totally do a quick reaction video next I
think I've been talking about a Punisher
series all year but now they've just
like officially come out and said we are
making this we just hired an executive
producer you'll probably see it next
year but because they're announcing it
so early and they're starting to hire
their staff I think they're gonna roll
into production later this year for like
a 2017 premiere date but lots more
awesome stuff coming and giveaway time
congratulations to this week's giveaway
winner young lava you win a $20 Amazon
gift card be sure to private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details that's
just on the about page I know there's
still a legends of tomorrow video that I
need to make I'll try and post that
later today they're just like a couple
things that I'm trying to get through so
I'll try and get through everything as
fast as possible while you guys wait for
my next video to post you can click here
for this week's episode of the flash and
you can click here for my spider-man
Civil War video thank you so much for
watching everybody looks like fun I'll
see you guys tonight